here okay by his own admission this
person actually tried marijuana in
college
so the doobie doobie pothead stoner of
the Year award goes to Andy Bernard a
lot of people I'd like to thank but I
think we all actually want to thank you
Michael oh thank you I mean we actually
really all want to thank you for
everything
my god something's happening
nine million nine hundred eighty six
thousand minutes we actually sat down
and did the math nine million nine
hundred eighty six thousand minutes
that's how many minutes that you worked
here in costumes and impressions in
meetings cups of coffee or birthdays or
meet example email boards hit me with
your car you helped me get off drugs I
watch you and you sleep I forgive you
for kissing me
[Music]
now okay
well this is gonna hurt like a mother
you'd like to encourage everyone to buy
our merchandise all the proceeds will go
towards lil Sebastian's favorite charity
the Afghan Institute of learning next we
have a special musical tribute by mr.
Andy Dwyer
what's 5,000 times better than a candle
in the wind this song is called 5,000
candles in the wind
up in horsey heaven here's a thing he
trains your legs for angel's wings and
once we've all said take
man you learned of line
[Music]
[Applause]
in
[Music]
so do you recognize any of these men I
was hiding in the bathroom stall so I
didn't see his face but I heard him he
was singing along to the music at the
bar do you remember what he was singing
I think it was that song I want it that
way
Backstreet Boys I'm familiar okay number
one could you please sing the opening
two I want it that way
really okay you are my fire number two
keep it going the one desire
number three believe when I say number
four I want it that way tell me why I
never wanna hear you sing kills literal
chills it was number five number five
killed my brother oh my god I forgot
about that part
everyone knows the most delicious part
of the muffin
a piece of that
[Music]
you're dumber than Apple so we're stuck
deciding to you all they stanley tried
to die just to get away yeah and now a
man who deserves no introduction Michael
Scott thank you very much thank you that
was great great job some great laughs
really really went after my intelligence
there ah dozens of online IQ test might
prove you wrong but and my thing isn't
tiny its average so get your facts
straight at home so when I heard that
there was going to be a roast in my
honor I thought no do that I don't like
this game
I don't know what the rules are okay
baby here's what I did tell me if this
is appropriate for a kid's song I
changed the lyrics insects hair - yeah
got sex bears you got him from me kids
Speirs legal sex bears anyway the word
hair was not the problem with sex hair
supposed to say it's time Andrew these
kids are tearing my house apart and I
need you to calm them with the power of
song
oh gosh here's the thing I can't do it I
got laryngitis
you will not bail on me and rude wire
you will perform my nephew was something
that outcast in his school I got Erica
swore vain to come which is a huge get
she rules the first grade and this party
will determine his social status for the
next hundred years so you better get out
there or I'm going to look at have you
not lost it well you don't even know hey
I'm freaking out listen to me
you make up songs all the time at the
top of your head you do you can do this
and afterwards we can have cake I
already had cake Andy okay stop you
little monsters not you Erica you're an
angel and we're thrilled you're here now
is everyone ready to hear the best music
you've ever heard and your miserable
little lives
okay then ladies and gentlemen please
welcome what even do you call yourself
yeah oh shoot light
please welcome Johnny karate and his
magical guitar stick okay it feels super
[Music]
do it all the time pick your nose his
boogers are gross
clean out your snout you can pick your
nose with your smelly toes
[Applause]
do it you're picking your nose II put on
your friend I started that great
everybody pees the bed just something
that we do I for instance peed the bed
till I was 30 to implement our batteries
my name is Burt Macklin
i investigate stinky feet for the FBI
[Music]
this is so fun I cannot believe this
only cost me 150 bucks
you